[Applaudissements]
les gars on dirait le gars du club med
papa
c'est le nouveau monde
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien franchement j'aime bien
joyeux et moi j'adore Sacha et c'est un
mec il est toujours sympathique toujours
sympathique
et c'est une petite boule d'énergie
oui qu'est-ce que tu veux faire ma
chronique par exemple ça va comment
regarder ils sont magnifiques il reste 9
émissions avec ça la neuf émission
deux fois ah mais tu as signé toi oui
mais il n'est pas le cas tous les deux
il me reste 9 donc ça veut dire c'est il
y a que deux tu travailles plus en deux
émissions que en 9 c'est pas faux c'est
pas faux et à mon avis vous allez
peut-être faire le ménage après les
images qui vont suivre puisque il y a un
truc qu'on adore et que les
téléspectateurs aussi je sais que vous
adorez cette séquence c'est le chocolat
on adore ça et
ceux qui l'aurai loupé regarde les
images je l'adore la question rejoins un
peu celle du goût on voit que depuis
quelques mois voir quelques années vous
avez entamé un régime strict pour être
au top physiquement c'est pas vraiment
un régime c'est vrai que je m'entraîne
beaucoup voilà mais voilà j'ai pas de
régime particulier d'accord justement
est-ce que vous vous interdisez des
aliments
j'en prends jamais et le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
on a fait toute cette séquence juste
pour ça applaudissement pour eux merci
chérie je retourne en plateau on arrive
dans 2 minutes qu'on est en parallèle
c'est magnifique
déjà vous avez remarqué comment Siri de
se battre le chocolat
mais il y a quelque chose que vous
l'avez pas vu ou en tout cas que vous
n'avez pas entendu et vous Cyril et vous
à la maison allez pas content ça va
Géraldine moyen
bien sûr alors il y a un truc qui n'ont
toujours pas compris vos chroniqueurs
Cyril pourtant ils font de la téloche
depuis quand même de nombreuses années
c'est ces micro là c'est micro on entend
tout bon ça risque de vous coûter cher
puisque on a capté tout leur
enthousiasme et leur joie quand ils ont
pris le chocolat dans la tronche j'adore
ce n'est pas content de la semaine
les pas content de la semaine
prochaine
parce que ça ça coûte 2000 balles et en
fait Thomas Lemoine il va avoir la
facture tu vois
là je déteste
en colère mais non c'est pas drôle
ah c'est dégueulasse en plus c'est du
chocolat éclaté ils vont avoir des notes
là ça va je vais mêler des défoncer
exprès
[Applaudissements]
je veux prendre en charge toutes les
notes de pressing et s'il faut changer
et les chaussures aussi je peux les
nettoyer grand seigneur non les paliers
[Rires]
pas non plus faire n'importe
quoi
vous inquiétez pas tout en charge vous
voyez bien sûr
c'est normal moi
ce que il revient au plateau tranquille
c'est pas mal frérot j'en ai
marre il est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui ferait pas pour
l'augmentation
vous allez peut-être vous reconvertir la
saison prochaine vous pouvez rassurer
que vous serez là la saison prochaine on
vous prépare vraiment une très belle
saison oui ou en tant que numérologue je
suis un peu les deux alors c'est vrai
que je suis un peu de la numérologie
le chemin de vie d'État numérologie
avec un chemin de vie je connais pas
si je pourrais
aller sur le chemin de fer tu vas
prendre le train
alors Cyril un cas peut-être plus simple
que le chemin de vie si je vous dis
Cyril c'est y aller 5 lettres
avec Daniel ça rend pas la même chose
c'est le numérologue de la semaine
de la semaine prochaine
ça marche à chaque fois rien comment ça
s'écrit Daniel avec deux l e Daniel
regarde bien je prends le déj je retire
un des moins un
le H le déplace les l je les transforme
en S une minute
le E je le garde
il me reste ni nier donc nier ça veut
dire que en fait quand on y on élimine
donc il me reste Daniel
= 7
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi
je l'ai fait à Hugo manos juste avant
il était comment vraiment
vous avez passé un diplôme
au-delà d'animer de présenter vous êtes
un peu obligé d'être l'arbitre de la
parole dans cette émission puisqu'il y a
beaucoup de débats
sauf que bah qui dit arbit dit parfois
aux malheur de certains chroniqueurs qui
essaient de parler et qui se prennent
bâche sur bâche Kelly en a fait les
frais cette semaine c'est la michkena de
la semaine
la miskina de la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine
est-ce que je peux participer au débat
les gars parce que vous regardez moi je
regarde moi je regarde je regarde que
mon compte je peux parler en tant que en
tant que jeune de la table bah vous
parlerez dans un instant ce qu'on doit
libérer Josiane et vous parlerez la
violence ça fait mal mais heureusement
Hugo bon camarade de la consoler comme
il peut la couleur tes yeux est trop
belle c'est vert
[Applaudissements]
j'adore Hugo il a vu qu'elle était pas
là mais j'ai dit
j'adore c'est que vous êtes un grand
amateur de lecture vous avez dévorer les
bouquins ce qu'on peut savoir ce que
vous avez sur votre table de chevet en
ce moment en ce moment je fais rien
qu'un de diamant
à la maison j'ai je crois que j'ai un
livre sur ah oui non ça y est c'est vrai
non j'ai un livre sur en fait qui est
sur l'origine du GPS
[Rires]
on dirait pas comme ça quand on le voit
mais pourtant
[Musique]
bon rêve tu sais ce que c'est
d'avoir une bibliothèque et je pourrais
dire tous les livres que je voudrais
pendant un mois
un peu chiant mais c'est un beau rêve
c'est moi la vie c'est la maladie c'est
la lecture
[Applaudissements]
alors vous qui aimez la lecture la
spiritualité on l'a vu et bien ça tombe
bien Karine soit là parce que est-ce que
vous avez des dilemmes philosophiques
quand vous levez le matin est-ce que
vous réfléchissez sur la vie quoi pas
comme dilemme par exemple déjà à quelle
heure je vais faire pipi alors oui il y
a pas de trucs un peu plus
philosophiques
j'aime bien brosser les dents et
regarder mes dents longtemps ouais ouais
vous matez quoi dans le miroir ok alors
on a exploré un peu les dilemmes que
vous avez dans dans votre vie parce que
vous avez une vie très compliquée
c'est le dilemme de la semaine vous
allez voir qu'en pub c'est les dilemmes
un peu différent
[Musique]
mauvaise haleine ça c'est le pire et la
deuxième c'est quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les discussions pendant les pubsents
on s'entend très bien j'adore c'est vrai
qu'on rigole j'adore parce que Hugo il
est hyper premier degrés
et comme il vient d'arriver il connaît
il connaît pas encore donc c'est vrai
que je peux les chauffer il répond
toujours présent vous pourriez parce que
eux c'est fini je vais les voir c'est
bon
avant de repartir sachez que c'est
comment tu crois pas je peux rester si
vous voulez
[Rires]
avant de partir c'est sachez que tu me
fais bien comment tu fais bien je sais
que j'ai un nouveau catalogue
d'imitation complètement pourri vas-y
c'est quoi alors mais c'est très gênant
les imitation alors je vous mets que sur
deux secondes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'envoie une image ou je détaille
un peu d'indique
[Musique]
lorsque Cyril
Hanouna entre avec son torse velu
c'est alors que selon plusieurs sources
alors ça reste à confirmer Gilles
[Applaudissements]
visiblement oui donc visiblement il
passera au parquet
dans les 15 jours non Michel apparemment
il va passer dans les deux jours
pour l'instant merci on a pas les mêmes
infos en tout cas on a pas les mêmes
infos voilà Myriam
vous pouvez faire un petit peu
alors donc que les dividendes
par une tierce personne donc il va le
garder donc surveillance populaire
demain il sera donc avec les copains du
speed
ouais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut le dire le bois de l'espace sur
les
publications
pour moi c'est cadeau
après j'en ai mais c'est c'est très ça
les tests dans les connaissent pas c'est
assistant les gens dans le dans la
société je lui dirai ça le directeur
général
[Applaudissements]
tu fais ce que tu veux
incroyable
avant de repartir donc sachez Cyril
qu'adore il adore faire quoi pendant
l'émission il adore chauffer les
chroniqueurs pendant les débats sauf que
vous
à la maison
plan sur Raymond par exemple il y en a
un qui est très facile à chauffer
justement c'est Raymond mais une petite
pièce dans la machine et là il part en
sucette vous êtes un peu le Jeff
panacloc c'est un peu votre Jean-Marc je
l'adore
bien que je sais comment le chauffer
c'est le c'est que tu as raison de la
semaine
tu as raison de la semaine
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les politiques ils
prennent leur téléphone et tweets
des hommes politiques je suis consterné
de la situation tu as raison le ministre
est réagit après trois semaines tu as
tellement raison bravo bravo tu as
raison mais prenez votre temps la
justice ça allait pas trop vite et
consterné par la vie
ah bon ça a chauffé là ouais parce que
elle a foutu le bordel faut que tu y
aille là
au lieu de venir là venez par là et
faites des choses tu aimes bien les
journalistes qui nous cite pas mais je
veux je veux pas qu'il nous aussi je
veux pas que les affaires elles existent
et les ministres et les ministres qui se
réveillent après qu'on sort les
histoires c'est bengous qui sort les
histoires c'est machin
et et les ministres les ministres mais
non tu me chauffes mais c'est pas bien
[Applaudissements]
mais non tu me choqué c'est pas bien
j'adore merci voilà c'est fini pour moi
et salut salut
[Applaudissements]